hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com
so as usual i'm here to make some
technical analysis with you guys i'm
here to show you
everything that i can see on the charts
and i'm here to explain to you
how to do it yourself so in this video i
want to take a step back
and make a bit longer-term analysis on
gamestop and show you some cool options
strategies
let's get into it
[Music]
all right so in my last video basically
i was explaining to you guys
what is happening here i was telling you
of course that the second wave is
expected
is healthy actually i like to have this
kind of corrections even if it's sharp
like this
it's fine it's not a problem for me we
having a nice
bullish development here that is
probably going to happen in five waves
so let me take a step back let me go on
the forest time frame
take a step back and show you quickly
here what is happening so once again i
have a target
of 800 i think we're gonna do something
like this
so you can already you know check so
basically 800 on the
around the 25th of august maybe maybe
we're gonna
go there quicker than expected maybe the
third wave is actually going to go to
800
you know it's possible as well then it
would arrive maybe in the around the
25th of july
it's too early to say i don't know
exactly what is going to happen
but i know that we are going higher all
right
the reason behind guys as usual is here
this breakout that we're having so after
breakout
we almost always having five waves
development
so here we just finished the first wave
so we are correcting to 220
maximum 190 180
you know for example amc re-tested this
trend line in amc chart that you can see
here
has been retested all right we broke the
same way
the trend line connecting the two highs
that we're having here we broke it and
then we tested it guys and we corrected
very
deep in the second wave before this
massive
massive move up we had 275 i mean 73 but
whatever
and here we might do the same thing so
just don't panic if you see the price
action
a bit weak once again i think monday is
going to be bullish and then i don't
know if we
starting a five waves development higher
or if we doing
a bit longer correction so maybe some
consideration
maybe we're gonna go slightly below i
don't know i don't care i know that
after
that whatever happens we are going to do
the third wave of
my five waves development here and this
is gonna be very interesting to
see so yeah once again in this video
guys i think it's the right time
uh for you to actually think about maybe
some
bullish option strategies so what i'd
like to do
with you guys is to show you so maybe
some of you know this
spreadsheet and i like to show you guys
how to build some cool option strategies
and what are the ones that professionals
are doing because
everybody can buy a call not everybody
can
do a smart option strategies depending
on the volatility here
option traders we call them vol traders
because what is important is the
volatility
so here i'm taking this data
so i'm going to do this with you guys up
to the 400 strike
copy paste then this is not an average
so i think
which is good is this is the last
trading price but what i want to have is
the average between the bid and the ask
then here michael look up needs to go
all right
so here we go so once again the basic
strategy guys you buy equal options so
call option on gamestop
it would cost you 1700 us dollars
and you can make if the game stop goes
to 100 you can make up to 40 000 us
dollars because
you have 100 multiplier so it's like
like having 100 equivalent shares so
this is not the strategy you want to
make you want to actually
buy the 400 strike and sell for example
the 800 strike
so this is on the july maturity you can
do it on every maturity
and here you can see that basically you
are buying a volatility at 193
and you're selling on volatility at 250
so you're selling a higher volatility
than the one you're buying this is the
reason why
this premium is lower so for 1000 us
dollars
you're having a cold spread so you can
make the same amount of money at 800
but it costs you less and the strategies
that i really like to do guys
is actually something that is even
cheaper that we call a butterfly sofa to
make a butterfly
you buy one 400 cold strikes here you
need to have a symmetry so for example
you can do it every 200 points so here i
just take this strike plus 200
here as well and here you need to have
something that
the sum of the options you're buying and
selling must be zero so you buy one
so when you buy one your payoff is like
this
then you sell two so then your payoff
is like this you buy one here then from
here you're losing if we go above 600
and you don't want to lose above 800 so
you cap your performance and here you
buy one as well
and now you can see guys that you can
make up to 20 000 us dollars
for only 500 usd and you're making this
money at 600
so it's a different piano profile that
is actually very interesting guys
because the volatility is so high
so the probability to finish at 600 on
the
16th of july is actually very low so
this strategy is actually tougher to
make you need to price uh very well
in time and spot what is gonna happen so
this is why i like to associate
option trading with technical analysis
that is giving me some
information if i use my chart and you
can go and check my videos in the past
and usually write
on the price action levels but also
in the timing and sometimes of course
i'm wrong because probably
trading is about probabilities and
expected gains but here you can see that
i
expect to trade in the 500 area
around you know the 15th of july so
i think that a strategy like this is
actually
for me uh very correlated to my analysis
so i think that's it's a very nice
payoff
for only 500 us dollars and if you want
to make
something because it's not easy to find
exactly the 600 level so you can make
another strategy that i want to show you
here which is called a condor
so condor uh sorry i need one more
strike
i'm just gonna do this quickly with you
guys okay we're gonna make it
every 100 points let me just
one second up i'm adding one more strike
to my strategy
then and then i'm gonna do this every
100 points
all right so for now i'm here still
having my butterfly
but this time i'm gonna do something
different i'm gonna sell one
here so we are like this i buy one i
sell one you know that so for 500 us
dollars you can have a 400 500 gold
spread
then you sell one more here instead of
selling two
you just sell the second one a bit later
so then
you are doing it here a basis which is
where you want to make your p
l and you cap your loss here so
basically now we're having a calendar so
maybe
we can do a condor studying at 500 and
this is a very nice strategy as well and
look guys it costs only 170
usd and you can make up to 10 000 if
gamestop finishes between
600 and 700 in july so this is something
that is for me likely to happen i mean
you know you can you only spend 170 us
dollars guys
so i think it's a very nice strategy and
of course you can make you know
just three times this if you prefer so
now you're spending 500 us dollars you
can make up to 30 thousands
all right once again because those
volatilities at 220 236 are very
expensive
so this is the kind of strategies i
would make i would
buy a condor i would buy a butterfly you
know
we call this condor you know and
butterfly just because here basically
you have the wings
and here you have the body so i would be
buyer of the wings sell off the body
this is how
we actually talk in the market all right
guys so that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video i hope
it was interesting for you to see how
you can combine technical analysis
and option trading i hope i managed to
be clear enough on this option
strategies which i know
is not easy but i'm gonna keep doing
this and slowly
you're gonna just look at this and say
yeah that is obvious and actually i know
how to do it myself
so if you enjoyed this video please
don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys